we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i have the
rare praise voicemail today this is just
a beautiful message of uplifting praise
very very rare if you listen to my
voicemails you would understand how just
how rare it is take a listen
hey david this is john from new york i
just wanted to take this time out thank
you genuinely for the work you've done
thus far on covering the pandemic crisis
and the daily presidential briefings in
particular it's been useful for someone
to provide perspective and even a bit of
levity in these dire days and times you
know many thanks keep spreading a good
fight and let you have our support right
beautiful message from john that was not
a plant just a really it's really great
to hear that and we've been doing the
daily press briefings i've been live
streaming them and providing commentary
there is some debate about whether I
should start skipping the Trump
propaganda part at the meeting at
beginning just mute that and turn the
volume up when the doctors actually
start speaking will see what people
think today on stream but yeah come on
down and join me join me for the live
streams let me remind you Thursday April
9th we are gonna try to do a membership
bomb in March because people are
tightening belts it's it's a bad
economic situation we had three hundred
and eighty nine membership cancellations
in March this was the most we've ever
had in any month okay so I don't want
anybody's last dollar times are tough we
get it but we want to avoid having to
you know reduce staffing reduce hours
any of that stuff we want to keep doing
more rather than less so to kind of try
to fight back against this Thursday
April 9th 2 p.m. Eastern 11:00 a.m.
Pacific an email will go out to
everybody on our mailing list with a
special membership coupon code the idea
is that day we want to try to recover as
many of these lost members as possible
so I invite you to sign up for my
newsletter sign up today david
pakman.com april 9th
you'll get an email with instructions on
how to take advantage of this one-day
special that's the goal get signed up
and you'll get access to the bonus show
as a member
on today's bonus show I will have the
latest for you on the producer Pat Forde
fire firefighters flood roof collapse
fiasco that producer pat has been
dealing with and I also have optimistic
news about Pat's upcoming heroic and
triumphant return to the bonus show all
of that and much more on today's bonus
show I'll speak to you then